hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the official sequel of
they come at poop time and I know you
all have been eagerly awaiting to see
what was in store the next time I tried
the poop in the middle of a forest
surrounded by demons and monsters the
pooj berry pooper
Pacific Rim para pupal activity which
I'm assuming this paranormal activity
and Scooby poo
honestly incredibly wonderful variations
of the the cult classics that we all
know of and love but with poo I've no I
don't know what the magic word is it poo
is poo the magic word no is it poop wait
hang on
poop damn all right whatever pooj how to
play it's it's that time of year again
the pooj everyone is going mental
oh the purge you could have just copied
the birds and everything would have been
fine everyone has gone mental killing
those they hate you are unfortunately
hated by everyone ain't that the truth
oh you just had a huge Mexican meal so
you've really thought to poop
you must defend yourself from intruders
by using traps and by repairing damage
you have two cameras set up in three
traps each to use a trap look at the
camera and press 1 2 or 3 on your
keyboard 1 being the first trap three
being the last oh boy all traps have a
cool-down after use you can see if
they're ready by looking at the light
under the camera
green means ready there's also a guy
trying to get in via the window it will
constantly be breaking the board's if
you be the borman's erepair by looking
the windows spamming e oh god oh god the
cameras are the main concern but don't
forget the window guy you strapped
wisely as they have a cool-down alright
here we go I guess oh boy oh oh it's not
free roam oh my god okay oh hello ha ya
missed whoa he dead okay well I missed
you oh I missed the Snoopy stomper okay
ah got him alright some guy come way oh
oh oh
he uh he uh Oh whoopsies oh god I've
ruined him he's gonna get me he's gonna
get me no no no no I'm pooping in here
no I'm no can't believe I can't believe
that didn't work I just need to get
coordination versus the traps the window
and everything else looking at these two
Oh all I want to do is poop oh okay
so we need you and you whoa that was a
shotgun I thought that was another ladle
talk about unnecessary deaths okay how
are you gonna die paper eyes now go away
please
I'm trying to that I'm boned already I'm
boned no I don't want to please just
give me some toilet paper and I'll be
fine a five-minute poop I mean seems
totally logical to me I guess that makes
other sense so I just got a I got a
study these ones and I'll get the fence
whenever that one comes by or does use
them as they need be in whatever you get
is what you get Oh
I spam dis hard oh okay okay you and you
Oh Papa I'm gonna get that last one
boink okay not on cooldown and you and
you oh you're dead now
stop that's my sweet poop window mom
you're just in time
why do they hate me so much I'm just an
innocent poop man oh no no no no no no
no man that window
maybe something tell oh i'm boner owned
okay you and you and you and you okay oh
my god and flying by the seat of my ass
oh boy yeah heads extra soup oh god I'm
gonna die what clever game mechanics you
gotta admit like for a simple shitty
game literally a shitty game you got you
gotta admit the mechanics are are rather
rather interesting okay you got another
one over there do not okay you and then
you and I can't press that fast enough
BAM I missed you but you know you and
then one and then yes oddly enough we're
good and I wouldn't have assumed that
what you say I don't I don't want to do
anything to your holes okay I fixed that
barely oh I almost missed that what are
you talking about [ __ ] nuggets I'll be
talking about my [ __ ] nuggets
I'm gonna wait till the last one for you
and the first two for you and that one
for you I got a pooping 220 220 that's
hardly enough poop time honk honk it
Blanc's if I just keep spitting oh ok
and long no that was not me
Paul yeah man I miss that one I'll get
you yes
ah not get you ok
I need to get that one later later as in
right now oh that sounded bad
okay ah [ __ ] I got split them up one
there oh no oh no did you oh okay I
don't know if spamming after the fact
this is so stress inducing I don't even
know why it's just a game about poop
okay
I'd like to think that funk is
pre-emptive and helping me because if
it's not then it's nah well glad I
answered that conundrum for everybody at
home who was curious about the status of
whether or not I'm boned or not you know
so for you so many people to soup in
this town Ram one the Rambam Oh oops
about you I'm not gonna miss you don't
talk about your Nuggets when I am around
Oh
oh no oh God okay I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm all good I'm good I'm good you
oh no I'm bad I'm bad I'm bad I'm bad
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I
got you want this swampy whoo one p one
for you oh this bad you and then you and
you okay I still got a chance but I'm
one minute away from poop town I guess
this is poop town USA but whatever oh
god I just missed that one oh I cannot
miss the first one in the next one I
just did exactly what I said I shouldn't
do oh no please please oh please please
I'm trying to prove I'm so close to poop
down Oh get smooshed I'm gonna put you
in the soup pot you get smooshed
I'm talking about the upside down those
the most stressful part stop oh gee you
made me mess up okay oh please please
okay you know what that's fine because
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you open 20 seconds remember
I've never been this concerned about the
status of my poop I bet the whole
Internet has never been this fast about
the status of my poop please tell the
world about the status of my poop
t-minus five seconds to poop time don't
don't don't
and remember that guys V V is the first
magic number letter now none magic
number one number one one per dumper one
is V you are the boy who didn't die you
just saved the world from you don't know
who now your next challenge awaits you
need to poo on the hog fart alright you
need you need to poo on the hog fart
Express you need to use this spells they
taught you at hog for it to survive the
toilets fart monsters who teachers and
Hooper in all seek to embarrass or kill
you one or the other you're either gonna
be horribly embarrassed or dead oh
really a toss-up fart monters god stop
that
we'll try and get in through the window
quickly you spell two to get rid of them
alright the teachers will sometimes walk
by and knock on the door you have to
answer them by pressing E on the door
the booper in will sometimes Oh
Slytherin right well sometimes throw
stink bombs inside if you breathe in too
much you will get knocked out you must
use spell number one at the create a
shield around you that blocks the stinky
gas the stink bomb will appear at the
bottom of the door because you were on
an old train the doors will sometimes
open due to turbulence if the teacher
reaches the door and it's open he will
get you you spell three to put the door
back and wide Harry pooper and the poop
inner of Aska poop Harry pooper and the
Goblet of poop
you know on the movie Dumbledore's like
okay anyway let's give this a go all
right I'm ready
birdie Butz almost every flavor beans
whoo but beer only nine I need no
pooping no oh well fell numbers great am
i what's that spell number three I don't
know what's happening no that ain't good
I'm creating a shield I think I'm not
creating I'm sure oh that's not good
oh that's a poop mentoring it get away
back Becky demon let me boo
all righty then obviously there's many
more amazing game modes left in this
here game so let me know down the
comments if you want to see more of it
also I wanted to take a second I know
it's awkward to take a second and get
kind of serious at the end of a freaking
poop related game but I just wanted to
say thank you again I mean I thank you
guys endlessly in the thank-you video
but I wanted to say thank you guys again
because I've always said that this
community is the most amazing community
on YouTube and I stand by those words
because not only do you guys let me take
the time I need to just find myself and
find what I want to do and take a break
if I need to and then come back stronger
than ever and have fun with making
videos again and try new things you guys
extend that to the rest of the community
you know even if I don't notice fan art
or stories or or gifts or things like
that or community creations like
animation do you guys let me know about
it or you guys just say how good it is
or how great people have progressed in
the community as artists and creators
themselves and there are so many
opportunities like that that you would
never see in any other community and I'm
eternally grateful for that and I want
to see more of it I would love to see
more of that carry through into every
other aspect of what we do here and
every avenue of the community and even
if you're just here to watch games or
watch sketches or whatever that's great
to just thank you guys for being here
and I can't wait to make more cool stuff
for you so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know if you want to
see more poop down the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]